the afternoon my name is Paul Cleary I'm
the Dean of the lco public
people world are still coming in but I
thought I would start by welcome you I'm
incredibly excited to welcome you to
this second conference of the Centennial
award of the CTA Winslow medal of the
Yale School of Public Health to dr. foul
cheating on behalf of the school I'd
like to stand our immense gratitude to
the faculty staff students and alumni
representatives that comprise both the
Winslow metal collect selection
committee and the Centennial planning
committee both chaired by our deputy
dean dr. Brian letterer for making this
historic occasion possible the Winslow
medal is given in honor of the founder
of our school and many would say the
founder of modern public health in the
United States is awarded to world
renowned innovators with distinguished
careers and outstanding achievement in
public health leadership scholarship and
contributions to society past recipients
include Sir Richard doll dr. William
faigy sir Iain Chalmers and Sir Michael
Marmot the final centennial medal will
be awarded in two weeks to dr. Judith
Rodin nominations for the Centennial
medal were sought from the entire yale
school of public health community from
the deans of schools of public health
across the country as well as from
leaders in the national institutes of
health the centers for disease control
and prevention and the World Health
Organization before introducing dr.
pouchy permit me to say a few words
about cea Winslow he was born in 1877 he
was educated at the Massachusetts
evinced Massachusetts Institute of
Technology in 1898 through 1899
respectively he taught at the University
of Chicago the city college of new york
and Yale inserted his editor of the
journal of bacteriology and the american
journal of public health was president
of the American Public Health
Association at Yale Winslow was chairman
of the university's first Department of
Public Health at its inception in 1915
in the course of his 30-year tenure he
brought Yale
the department and himself considerable
international and national distinction
and acclaim the world's changed a lot in
the last hundred years but science has
changed too during that time hygiene
developed into preventive medicine
bacteriology evolved to include
parasitology and virology classic
epidemiology evolved to include clinical
epidemiology control of communicable
diseases became chronic disease control
and public health increasingly focused
on social determinants of illness and
health Winslow developed public health
into a premier educational program that
graduated not only students with masters
and doctoral degrees in public health
but also medical students imbued with as
he would say a preventive spirit Yale
was the first academic institution in
the u.s. to recognize the importance of
Public Health establishing a degree
granting program in this field and in
1946 the program was one of the first
eight groups of schools to be nationally
accredited as a school of public health
many of the advances made in public
health nationally and internationally
during the last half of the last century
were made by those who followed Winslow
at Yale such as John rod and Paul
Dorothy horseman Jim niedermann John
Thompson max the air and Jordy castles
the evolution of the Yale School of
Public Health has continued in more
recent decades building on the
intellectual vision of Winslow as
evidenced not only by the research
achievements of our faculty but also by
our many graduates who have gone on to
become exceptional public health leaders
100 years after the inception of our
school and with infectious diseases and
access to care and treatment continuing
to be formed of global health challenges
it is a fitting to award the CEA Winslow
metal to dr. pouchy rated x rated by
Fortune magazine is one of the world's
50 greatest leaders of our time as the
people in this audience well known
dr. Fuji is the director of the niaid at
the National Institutes of Health since
his appointment as director in 1984 dr.
Fuji has overseen an extensive research
portfolio devoted to preventing
diagnosing and treating infectious and
immune-mediated diseases dr. Fuji is
also chief of the niaid laboratory
immunoregulation where he has made
seminal contributions to the
understanding of how HIV destroys the
body defenses leading to its
susceptibility to deadly infections
further he has been instrumental in
developing highly effective strategies
the therapy of persons living with
hiv/aids as well as for a vaccine to
prevent HIV infection he continues to
devote much of his research time to
identifying the nature of the
immunopathogenesis vian fection and the
scope of the body's immune response to
HIV dr. pouchy serves as one of the key
advisors to the White House and
Department of Health and Human Services
on global AIDS issues and on initiatives
to bolster medical and public health
preparedness against emerging infectious
diseases threats such as been demek
influenza he was one of the principal
architects of the president's PEPFAR
program which has already been
responsible for saving millions of lives
throughout the developing world dr. Fuji
is a member of the US National Academy
of Sciences and as the recipient of
numerous prestigious awards for his
scientific and global health
accomplishments including the National
Medal of Science the Mary Woodward
Lasker Award for public service and the
Presidential Medal of Freedom he has
been awarded 42 honorary Doctorate
degrees and is the author co author or
editor those of you in this audience who
think you've been productive of more
than 1200 in 70 scientific publications
including several major textbooks in
some there are a few people in the field
of Public Health who have had such a
profound impact on global health and
infectious diseases
and the spirit of Winslow this work has
evolved extensive communities of
professionals and laypersons which
directly promote Winslow's goal of
preventing disease and promoting health
it is us an extraordinary honor and
privilege for me to present the
Centennial cea Winslow metal to our
steam gasps dr. pouchy please welcome
dr. pouchy go see this man magical thank
you very much
and she's holding that good job this
time I've been told not to drop this on
the floor thank you for thank you Paul
for that very kind introduction it's
really a wonderful pleasure to be here
with you this afternoon and an
extraordinary honor to receive the the
Winslow metal from from Yale School of
Public Health the subject that I'm going
to talk to you about today if one looks
at the first slide may seem when one
thinks of the epidemiology of this
extraordinary pandemic as to maybe be a
bit over the top that we're going to be
able to end this pandemic but I hope to
develop with you over the period of this
discussion is the scientific basis why
not only do I think that this is
achievable and I'll get back to it in a
bit but i think it's it's almost
inevitable that it will happen if we do
a few things and what it's going to be
it's going to be an interdigitating
between the discovery of the science
that gives us a good basis to do this
and importantly the implementation of
that science so let me get on with it
and I hope that you'll understand the
threads that I'm going to be putting
together for you on this so first let's
look at the nature of the problem so I
press down and it didn't move so then
let's try this okay
oh I did something wrong so I pressed I
usually press the arrow that says go and
it goes but it's not going so where's
that wonderful young lady who I gave my
wallet too but I don't trust you anymore
okay so this is the error that says go
right okay there you go thank you you
can keep the wallet okay so the numbers
are very daunting and that's what I was
saying when I was alluding just a moment
ago why this seems like such a lofty
goal if you look at the numbers we've
gotten so used to the numbers that we
almost take them for granted now both
internationally and domestically so
there have been 76 million people
infected with HIV 34 million deaths 37
million people living with HIV and the
number that says disturbing as the
history of this is what's actually going
on right now the ongoing pandemic with
1.2 million deaths and 2 million new HIV
infections when I make rounds on my
patients and when I talk in my lab
meetings it's very difficult because
most of the fellows were actually not
born at a time than when there was no
hiv/aids so they didn't know a world
without aids so they take for granted
something that we need to keep
emphasizing that in the short list like
a handful of the major scourge is on
human civilization this ranks in the top
few the bubonic plague pandemic flu of
1918 the smallpox outbreaks etc it's not
only globally in the United States where
again this complacency there's 1.2
million people living with HIV
interestingly and I'm going to get back
to this because this is huge thirteen
percent of people who are infected in
the United States don't know that
they're infected I'll get back to why
that's so important
they have been over six hundred and
fifty thousand deaths and fifty thousand
new infections over the past two decades
the two parts about this bullet that are
disturbing is the 50,000 number and the
two decades number because if you were
with several of a couple of see people I
see in the audience that were around
then in the beginning of the epidemic
the number of cases per year were doing
this and it piqued like around 120 140
thousand a year then it came down to 50
but the problem is it stayed at 50 for
almost two decades now we're going to
get back to that the demography has
changed it was in the beginning in the
early 80s a middle-class young white gay
man with some percentage of injection
drug users now it's predominantly gay
men mostly african-american we'll get
back to that in a second and their
youths the infections now twenty five
percent of them more are in I think at
least when I look at myself in the
mirror children between the ages of 13
and 24 but that's what the demography is
so a more graphic representation of this
if you look at the pie chart in the last
recorded numbers in the United States
and look at the United States Puerto
Rico in other areas sixty-five percent
among men who have sex with men more
than fifty percent of which are
african-american seventeen percent among
heterosexual females eight percent among
heterosexual males and the four percent
for injection drug users was a bigger
slice of the pie in the 80s we did
something really simple despite the lack
of federal support for that was needle
and syringe exchange which completely
turned around the reason I tell you that
now in the beginning of the lecture
because that was the implementation of
something that was really simple and now
we're going to have to start
implementing things that are a little
bit more complicated so if you look at
what's happened in the field the
extraordinary amount of investment that
has been made in
basic and clinical biomedical research
on HIV it is true to say that an amazing
amount has been accomplished
breathtaking in many respects when you
think of what's happened in the areas on
the slide none more impressive or
important than the arena of treatment
and I have to give examples before the
Congress about the relationship between
basic research and applied research and
an endpoint in health just look at the
treatment of HIV infection from the very
beginning so this is a picture of
Believe It or Not Me in 1981 in January
taking care of one of my hiv-infected
individuals I show that picture it makes
me smile a little because I had all
black hair then but it also makes me sad
a bit because I still can't get all over
the feeling that I had for many years
from 1981 into the 90s where almost all
of my patients died well the reason is
they came in with advanced HIV infection
because we didn't know was HIV until
they were sick enough to get into the
hospital so when this picture was taken
the median survival of my patients were
anywhere between eight months and a year
a year and a half it got a little better
as we got better at treating
opportunistic infections but until we
developed a drug you could look a
patient in the eye when they asked you
to honestly tell them what lies ahead
and it was really rather bleak so what
happened what started was an
extraordinary assault in the area of
science of looking at fundamental basic
issues and that's what I meant when I
said how we can justify all of the money
that we put into HIV and the money that
we have to keep putting into HIV so this
is a schematic diagram that I'm sure is
very familiar to members of the audience
of the HIV replication cycle with all
the things we understand about the issue
of binding fusion entry reverse
transcription integration then budding
with protease enzyme involved and what
this has led to as
we all know was the first drug AZT was
actually a cancer drug which shows you
about the interdigitating between
disciplines that was a reverse
transcriptase inhibitor but most of
what's happened since then has been
targeted drug development now there was
targeted antiviral drug development
before HIV with some of the herpes
viruses and others but targeted drug
development has really come into its own
in the arena of HIV such that if you
look at all the great advances that we
see now with hepatitis C which is
actually curable is based fundamentally
on the advances that were made in
targeted drug development for HIV so
what was the result of that the result
of it over years starting off with a
single drug than two drugs and then the
transforming year of 1996 when we first
had the triple combinations which were
with a protease inhibitor and nucleoside
reverse transcriptase inhibitors which
is now for the most part been replaced
by integrase inhibitors and other types
of targets we now have about 30 of these
which when used in combination you
already know have completely transformed
the lives of hiv-infected individuals so
in the same room where I showed you that
picture of me on a patient I made rounds
what's today Friday on Wednesday with a
person that came in similar I'm not
making this up for the for the for the
effect of the lecture when a person came
in completely undiagnosed for the first
time I looked him in the eye was a 21
year old hispanic individual that when
we put him on drug we could tell him if
he takes his drug that he will likely
live an additional 50 50 years until
he's into his mid-70s so let's take a
look at this now when you look at the
application of antiretroviral therapy
there are two aspects of it one is
obvious treatment but I'm going to get
to in a few minutes another aspect of
antiretroviral therapy which has emerged
over the years as almost as important
when you think of the Broads
scope of the epidemic so here's the
chart that I was referring to you so if
a young person came in early on with no
of few drugs they had a dismal life
expectancy now it's about 71 years if
they come in at age 20 and you could do
all the modeling about why this is the
case this is not only now in the
developed world because with PEPFAR the
Global Fund the Gates Foundation the
Clinton Foundation right now what we
have is 15 million people receiving
antiretroviral therapy when I went down
to when President Bush sent me to Africa
in 1982 to start the development of the
beginnings of the PEPFAR program they
were less than 50,000 people in lower
middle-income countries who are
receiving a RT now there are 15 million
which means that over a period of about
14 years almost 8 million lives have
been saved and again I tell this or this
audience that knows that of this is the
greatest argument you can have for
investment in biomedical research that
leads to a results because we often get
asked when I get before the Congress
what have you done for us lately we're
putting so much money into it what have
you done this is what the biomedical
research community has done it if you
look at the numbers they speak more than
forty percent decrease in deaths in the
last un aids report so that's treatment
what about prevention well when we
started off in the early 80s they were
very low tech even non medically related
things attire armamentarium has emerged
first there was the use of condom
behavioral modification then clean
syringes and needles and then we started
to integrate medical interventions with
prevention such as medical male
circumcision prevention of
mother-to-child transmission treatment
as prevention which we'll get into in a
moment and a variety of others with all
of these and i'll get back to some
aspects of them in a moment again the
numbers have dramatically changed
with a decrease of more than thirty five
percent of new infections since 2000 an
amazing amount of accomplishment but
much more to be done and that gets back
to the theme of my first slide why I
think we can actually turn around the
trajectory of the epidemic if we do it
correctly so let's start with some
fundamental principles the foundation
for all HIV treatment and prevention
efforts is testing for HIV that seems
really rather simple but it's very
difficult to implement that the CDC is
now recommend that everyone gets tested
at least once and people at high risk
can get tested as often as every three
to six months depending upon the risk
category so let's take a look at what
happens when you test somebody things
have changed over the last several years
so one of two things happen you either
test positive or you test negative so
let's look at what happens if you test
positive there's a phenomenon called the
care continuum now the care continuum
means from the time you get infected to
the time you are on therapy your viral
load is below technical detectable level
and we know from studies that I'll get
into in a moment that means it is
extremely unlikely that you're going to
infect anybody else that's the care
continuum so how are we doing with the
care continuum I mentioned that thirteen
percent of the people who are infected
in the United States don't know that
they're infected I'm going to get back
to that number in a second because
that's very important here's where we
drop off really badly of the 1.2 million
people infected only thirty-nine percent
of them are receiving medical care
thirty-six percent have been prescribed
an antiretroviral drug and dismal e
thirty percent of them are virally
suppressed which means they're saving
their own lives and they're not
infecting anybody else now that's in the
United States as a whole there are some
they're doing much better than that
Hopkins is doing much better the Ryan
White group is doing much better San
Francisco doing much better but as a
country it's thirty percent so if I were
playing 20 questions what country in the
world is doing much better than we are
Rwanda Rwanda is doing much better than
we are because if you look at the number
of people infected the number of people
on there we'd have about seventy plus
percent of their people are virally
suppressed so we have a ways to go now
this is the slide that blows me away if
you ask a question who is infecting whom
in the United States of the thirteen
percent of people who don't know they're
infected they're infecting thirty
percent of the 50,000 people who are
getting infected each year now talk
about failings of medical care if you
look at the people to a diagnosed but
not in care they are infecting 61
percent of the people who are getting
infected which means if you just
diagnose somebody with HIV and put them
in care that you would be decreasing by
91% the number of infections in this
country so i can actually stop the
lecture right now and say if we just did
that you would have the curve do this
but we're not doing it so let's take a
look at some of the things that we can
do this issue of diagnosed but not in
care is is a real phenomenon it's not
just a statistic a common occurrence
that I experienced when I make rounds on
my ward at the NIH is someone usually
hispanic or an african-american who went
into a clinic two or three years ago
because of a broken leg or got shot
somewhere in washington d.c got an HIV
test and then was lost to care and then
comes in now at a cd4 count of four and
multiple opportunistic infections that
is not an uncommon situation in this
country so some of you may heard of
the 90 90 90 targets so that's a UN aids
target now which says that if you take
ninety percent of the people are
infected and diagnose them and take
ninety percent of those and put them on
treatment and take ninety percent of
those and virally suppressed them you
will encompass about seventy-three
percent of the people who will be
virally suppressed you do a mathematical
model of that the trajectory of the
epidemic does that so although this is a
goal if we accomplish it we can do
exactly what my first slide said so
let's see how the United States is doing
on 90 90 90 the goal is to get there by
2020 so the blue is 2020 the red is
where we are now we're not doing that
bad with diagnosis courses yet only
thirteen percent of individuals are not
diagnosed even though they comprise
thirty percent of the new infections but
take a look at the on treatment how
badly we're all behind the goal and look
at the virally suppressed so clearly we
have a long way to go so I've had two
over the past year or so make some
arguments one when I was working with
the people in New York State when
Governor Cuomo was putting together his
blueprint for ending the AIDS epidemic
in New York State and now I'm working
with some of my colleagues in the White
House to try and put together a program
to make some model cities I always get
asked as everybody does what is the
scientific basis for investing so much
money to do this because when you're
dealing with government funds they
always need to know the scientific basis
of doing it rather than just throwing
money at it so let's look at the
scientific basis turn the clock back ten
years you can actually turn it back more
than that but in the beginning when we
were treating people with multiple drugs
sometimes two and then we got the triple
combination the big question was if you
start somebody early is the cumulative
toxicities of the drug worse than having
somebody beaver emic continually there
was a real argument about that so we did
a study about ten years ago called a
smart study and the question was should
you treat somebody
only when their cd4 count drops below a
certain level and then when it comes
back up stop therapy so that at the end
of a period of time there'll be some
people who are on therapy for a longer
period of time and others who beyond
therapy for a shorter period of time and
the answer was unequivocal the things
that we thought the drug was doing with
toxicity was due to chronic viremia and
immune activation so that's the first
thing the second major study was the
treatment as prevention study the
now-iconic HPT no.52 typical study that
was randomized study controlled
discordant couples starts someone early
on therapy the infected person wait to
start the infected person and compare
what the rate of infection from the
infected partner to the uninfected
partner again unequivocal if you start
right away ninety-six percent decrease
in infections that are transmitted
that's referred to as i know many in the
audience know that for those who don't
it's the treatment as prevention
approach then the people who had trouble
with that said now wait a minute if you
start somebody with a high cd4 count who
feels well it's good for the public
health because you're preventing
infection but is it really good for the
person so we did another study called
the start study which you asked just
that question treat people who are over
500 no matter what their count is or
wait till it drops to 350 and guess what
happened the people who were treated
early unequivocally did better than the
people that were waiting which tells us
something very important right now if
you look at the individual benefit and
the public health benefit there's
absolutely no excuse whatsoever not to
treat every person who's HIV infected
with an antiretroviral drug period case
closed the reason I get animated about
that as I've spent years arguing about
that and now we have all the scientific
data we need to do that in fact on the
basis of
our studies the wh 0 a few weeks ago
came out with the recommendation that
all people living with HIV should be
offered any retroviral in addition to
all of the other things we give to them
now the real question is how are we
going to get the resources to have them
to be able to implement that and that's
again the implementation gap let's move
quickly on to prevention continuum
because years ago when we were a little
bit lacks we would say if you're
infected will put you on therapy if your
test is negative you're really great
thank you goodbye have a nice day that's
not what we do anymore because the
people who are at risk who are negative
need to get into a continuum that's
exactly the same as if they were
infected and that continuum is
counseling stratifying which risk you're
in and depending upon your risk are you
a gay man or you injection drug user are
you in a discordant relationship and to
provide them with that toolbox of
prevention which was that circle ring
that I showed you you want to retain
them in service and you want to have
them adhere adhere to prevention the
same way as you want someone who's
infected to adhere to treatment so what
else has evolved over the last several
years and that is the use of therapy as
prevention in the early years of the
AIDS epidemic there was a reluctance
because that's the way the field of
infectious disease was was to treat
someone who wasn't infected to prevent
them either getting an opportunistic
infection or getting HIV that is all
changed right now because there are at
least four areas we're treating an
uninfected person in this case
preventing mother-to-child transmission
by treating the infected mother so the
baby doesn't get infected pre-exposure
prophylaxis post-exposure and i already
told you about treatment as prevention
let's examine just a couple of those
because i don't have time for all of
them pre-exposure prophylaxis that means
giving an antiretroviral drug to someone
is at risk for infection I could show
you two slides full of studies which
indicate that it is ninety-five percent
effective if you take the drug if you
don't take the drug it's not effective
there was a nice study from Kaiser
Permanente in San Francisco which just
asked that question let's take people
who are at risk and give them truvada
let's take people who are at risk and
wait a year again there were no
infections in the people who got rivara
treatment as prevention works in
Baltimore you put people on therapy the
incidence decreases in Rwanda you put
people on therapy it decreases the
incidence so I'm going to spend the next
period of time I'll stay on time talking
to you about cure and vaccine the two
last challenges there's my water there
can somebody get me some water thank you
putting all my energy into this I'm
Canady hydrated
okay so I already told you when you put
somebody on therapy you can load the
level of virus they'll do well you
increase their expectancy by 50 years
I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about the cure there are two things that
people are talking about the cure one is
to eradicate the virus now that's very
difficult with HIV because HIV
integrates itself into the genome so you
can suppress the virus do very well but
not be cured in the classical sense if
your definition of cure is to have
prolonged if not indefinite remission
without the need of antiretroviral
therapy now there are two ways that you
can do that one is really difficult and
that is to eradicate the virus we've
tried for years to do things like flush
out the virus by activating the cells
while they're receiving antiretroviral
in the hope that you would activate all
of the latent ly infected cells and be
left with no cells infected it doesn't
work that way because despite a
considerable amount of effort thus far
we've not been able to do that then
there are more draconian approaches such
as immunotoxins era p directed at the
reservoir stem cell transplants you
heard about the Berlin patient now I'm
really glad that the Berlin patient is
alive and doing okay but the Berlin
patient developed a leukemia that
required chemotherapy to allergen a
transplants with someone who has a
genetic defect that the virus can infect
the cells and is currently on a minute
suppressive therapy that's not practical
for 37 million people who are HIV
infected it's a very interesting proof
of concept but that's not something
you're going to do
gene therapy gene editing very exciting
I'm going to have to hold judgement
about where we're going one of the ways
that's probably more doable but we're
still in the process of doing
experiments we're doing experiments in
my own lab and in several other labs is
to try and control the viral rebound
discontinuing drug but not necessarily
trying to eradicate the virus and the
ways you do that is you rely on natural
hiv-specific immunity we've tried that
I've tried personally discontinuing
therapy in a large number of people and
with very few exceptions everybody
rebounds so somehow or other we don't
like and I'll get back to that with
vaccines the other thing that's really a
hot topic that you keep your eye on is
the passive transfer of HIV specific
antibodies sort of like the old days of
passive immunotherapy weeds to give as
well as therapeutic vaccines which would
then hopefully allow you to discontinue
therapy with sustained control of I
remya the message I want to leave with
this group and I didn't go into any
great details about the science of cure
is that when you're talking about cure
it really needs to be simple it needs to
be safe and it needs to be scalable
because in my mind curing nine people
that make the front page of the new york
times when there were 37 million people
are infected is kind of interesting for
nature and science and whatever but it's
not interesting from the standpoint of
the epidemic and the pandemic itself
I'll be happy to answer questions about
that one I finish all right vaccine so
now this is exciting it's exciting
because it's a challenge but it's
exciting because it's really unique in
immunology and the interdigitating
between a microbe and the immune system
and let me explain what I mean by that
now the talk I gave you about we already
have the tools to do what we need to do
if we just implement them if you listen
carefully you could
a then G why do we really need a vaccine
well I gave a version of this lection
all of my vaccine colleagues started
emailing me what are you doing you're
trying to put us out of business so I
had to write an article in New England
Journal of Medicine ending AIDS is an
HIV vaccine necessary so I submit to you
yes if you're a vaccine ologist don't
worry about it and the reason is I think
you're going to have to have a vaccine
for a quicker getting to the goal post
but importantly a durable end to the
epidemic because what we've seen with so
many infectious disease malaria is the
typical prototype of that you get into
region you get down omis to where you
want to be and then people stop putting
an effort into it and it bounces back
that's one of the important reasons why
you need a vaccine so let me tell you
about vaccines because it's really an
interesting historical story if you look
at the history of axon ology I want to
divide it into two approaches what I
call the empirical or inductive approach
and the theoretical or deductive
approach let me explain empirical means
you test a candidate just empirically
typical kill vaccine live attenuated
vaccine until you get protection and
then you try to improve upon that to get
an effective vaccine the theoretical
approach is more cautious more
scientific more arid I that means let's
figure out what we're trying to induce
first and then fashion the vaccine to
induce that now if you look at the
empiric or inductive approach
essentially every vaccine that we've
ever successfully developed has been
through the empiric approach so let me
explain that vaccine ologist have a
paradigm and that is that mimic natural
infection so whether it's smallpox
measles polio you get morbidity
mortality but ultimately the body clears
the virus of the infection you're left
with immunity that in most cases is
lifelong so nature has already done the
proof of concept for you what you need
to do is mimic natural infection and
that's what we've done with all of the
vaccines we've even given a whole
vaccine killed or an attenuated
unfortunately we don't have that grace
as it were with HIV because natural
immunity is not very good so this is a
complicated slide that is the historical
menu of what we've done from the early
approaches in 1987 in which we did
trials of envelope induced non
neutralizing antibody didn't get
protection were completely puzzled I was
one of those in fact for the first
vaccine trial that was done with an
fda-approved product was done in the NIH
Clinical Center by my colleague cliff
Lane in which we just gave an envelope
to someone and said hey we're gonna wind
up getting an antibody and that'll be it
yeah we got an antibody but the antibody
was only good against lab adapted
strains and didn't do anything to
primary isolates then we switched over
to t cell vaccines to try and suppress
the set point of the virus make a long
story short we were quite unsuccessful
but there was one success and that one
success was an empirical approach in
which a prime boost of a vaccine was
done in Thailand now referred to as RV
144 which had thirty one percent
efficacy not-ready-for-prime-time but at
least you had something to work on so
now that fits right into the empiric
approach you now have a proof-of-concept
try to improve on it and that's exactly
what's going on and the interesting
surprise the one thing that's great
about science you all know this your
scientist is that it's full of surprises
so when we got to thirty one percent
efficacy we thought we find the clear
correlative immunity at initializing
anybody or cytolytic T cells
everybody was looking at cytolytic
t-cells we found out it was in anybody
that was an IgG against a region of the
envelope that we never paid any
attention to because it was a variable
region so we didn't think it meant
anything that's the first surprise the
second surprise is that it wasn't
neutralizing it was an ADC see anybody
anybody dependents le cytotoxicity there
was no cd8 cytolytic cells and
interestingly if you made an IgA
antibody against it you blocked the
response so everything about our
paradigm was wrong it wasn't
neutralizing there were no CTLs and it
was against the region that we never
would have guessed so what are we doing
now we're trying to improve upon it
increase the strength the breath and the
durability with multiple different types
of approaches more boosts modified
vectors or adjuvant so now we get to the
stuff that's really exciting but I have
to hold judgment as to whether or not
we're even going to be possible to be
successful and that is the theoretical
approach and that means so I'll go slow
in this follow me because it really is
very interesting that is that we know
that the gold standard of vaccines is to
induce a neutralizing antibody that
covers all strains that's referred to as
a broadly neutralizing antibody okay
what's the problem with HIV is that
broadly neutralizing antibodies are only
induced in about twenty percent of
hiv-infected individuals and by the time
they induce it their virus is not
sensitive to it bad news number one
number two it usually takes them two
years of continual viremia to induce a
broadly neutralizing antibody most of
them have a hard degree of somatic
mutation for those of you not familiar
with that that means that you've got to
stimulate in and out of the germinal
Center multiple times before you get the
anybody
that's not practical for a vaccine and
the other one is they have a very
interesting trait of order reactivity so
with that as a background the field
decided let's do it in a theoretical way
and try to track this down so this is a
blow-up of the HIV this is the HIV
virion and this is the trimer or the
triple component of the envelope protein
that by any virus usually if you make it
anybody that's neutralizing against that
you're home free you got a good vaccine
ok so these squigglies are any bodies
that are monoclonal antibodies and you
know we always try to confuse people by
giving it strange names like lea RC 0 1
and 10 e8 for those of you who work in
the laboratory that's the tenth tray the
ear 08 down hello so these are
antibodies that have been developed that
have been cloned from people who are HIV
infected who have their part of that
twenty percent developed neutralizing
antibodies so what does that tell us the
thing is that it binds to a certain part
and if you get rid of the antibodies
these are called epitopes which are
neutralizing epitopes which means that
if the antibody binds to this then you
want to make a response against this
epitope so the critical challenge that
we have right now is how do you get
these neutralizing epitopes to turn them
into an immunogen to induce the broadly
neutralizing antibody that seems like
pretty simple just go do it not really
so what happens we find out that two
important critical factors in the
induction of antibody one is the
stability of the envelope trimer and the
other one is engaging the b cell lineage
so I'll get I'll simplify it and make it
very clear that even those who don't
work in this area will understand it
what do we mean by the stability of the
HIV envelope okay let me show you
characteristics of the envelope it's
naturally unstable it isn't a protein
that stays this way it moves around and
flips around it has conformational
changes number two the envelope changes
upon binding to cd4 and it exposes an
immunodominant part of the epitope by
immunodominant means it sucks up all the
immune response and the immune system
makes a response preferentially against
one region versus another the problem is
that anybody's to be three have limited
neutralization activity stable trimeric
envelopes preferentially by neutralizing
anybody so we come to the conclusion
that you want a stable envelope and this
could serve as the preferred imogen so
we now know that so what do I mean by
instability let me march through it with
you let's go back to this envelope with
this epitope here if I super impose upon
that the structural biological
squigglies that you usually see when
people show the structural biological
confirmation this is what it looks like
so I'm going to pull out the schematic
and leave you with this so this is the
pre fusion HIV envelope by unstable we
mean that when the envelope binds to the
cd4 molecule it starts doing funny
things one of the things it does is it
flips out this protein is v3 loop the
problem with that as I showed on the
other slide is that antibodies that are
now going to be preferentially made
against this while ignoring all these
others have very limited neutralizing
activity which finally after 20 years
explains why when we were given the
envelope we were getting any bodies that
were neutralizing anything because the
immune system was being directed against
doing something that was irrelevant to
protection so this is the stable
envelope when the envelope is stable
neutralizing antibodies all bind to
these in a very very clear way which
means that this is the preferred imogen
for vaccinations so now we know after
many years that the preferred imogen is
the stable envelope a couple of really
good studies from John Moore at Cornell
jamba scholar and my group and Peter
Kwang show that you can actually get in
a crystal structure a conformational e
fixed and stable envelope so you would
think okay now we have the envelope it's
going to be easy how do you engage the
proper sequential engagement of the B
cell lineage what do we mean by that
Bart Hanes two years ago did an
interesting experiment that was an
experiment of nature happened to get
hold of someone who was being followed
very carefully in a prevention study who
got infected and the first antibody that
was made is referred to as the unmutated
ancestor antibody what it is is non
neutralizing and what happened was that
as the antibody was made the virus
mutated to escape the antibody another
antibody was made the virus mutated to
escape that anybody none and they kept
on doing this for two years until
finally you got a broadly neutralizing
anybody so the thought occurs now is
that perhaps if you really want to mimic
natural infection HIV is doing something
that no other virus is doing why don't
we and Michelle listen spike from New
York articulated this in a review
article why don't we have a vaccine that
iteratively stimulates the immune system
till it matures to the next stage and
then another image into mature so that
you could over a period of months
hopefully trigger the development of
broadly neutralizing antibody the one
problem with that is that the epitopes
here are not
cognize by any germ line B cells that
are in your b cell lineage so you have
to figure out what the proper immunogen
is to start the process off and that's
not going to be easy it's it sounds very
difficult and confusing it's certainly
difficult and it is starting to be done
in recent papers that just came out over
the summer in which they've done knock
in mice and and and and and non-human
primates were they were able to engage
the B cell lineage to start to do this
again it's not going to be very easy and
in fact it's probably one of the most
imp uh I would think profound challenges
in vaccinology that we have ever faced
in history I've never seen anything like
this where you're trying to get the
immune system to do something it doesn't
really want to do for natural infection
so before I close let me just a couple
of more comments about while we were
doing all of this work I'm broadly
neutralizing antibodies and identifying
it and cloning it there is now a bunch
of studies that are saying well if you
can't make the body do the neutralizing
antibody can you actually passively
infusion and there are a number of
studies now that for prevention and
treatment are using passive transfer of
antibodies either alone or by just
inserting the genes of the antibody into
a vector and then just inserting that
into the host so it's interesting
because it's you know the we used to do
this sixty years ago when you were doing
passive transfer for things like the
theory ER and things like that but we're
starting to think about that now finally
the t-cell approaches obviously there
are a number of things that are going on
T cells are very important to provide
help to B cells but also particularly
some experiments that were done by Luke
picker and his colleagues indicate that
under the right circumstances cd8
positive T cells could be induced to
kill hiv-infected cells so with regard
to a vaccine let's go back to what I
told you that the RV 144 the tide
it was forty thirty one percent
effective that's no good it's not going
to make primetime the measles vaccine as
I use as a paradigm is ninety-eight
percent effective which means that if
you take a shot when you're 11 to 12
months when you're supposed to take it
and then you come back at four to six
years which is your booster it's about
ninety-eight percent effective which is
the reason why I got so upset when
mothers were not wanting to vaccinate
their children against measles is one of
the most effective it is the most
effective vaccine we're not going to get
a ninety-eight percent effective HIV
vaccine I just can't see how that's
going to happen but somewhere in between
whether that's 50 55 60 percent together
with non vaccine prevention I think
that's going to be the durable nail in
the coffin of HIV I think we're going to
put some nails in even without the
vaccine but the durable nail is going to
be so with treatment and the
comprehensive HIV prevention this is the
end point and this is the goal so this
is my last slide and I want to just make
just a comment or two about that five
years ago my colleague and I Greg focus
wrote a paper at a time when I just
started thinking about this and I
entitled the paper controlling and
ultimately ending the AIDS pandemic a
feasible goal now as my first slide it's
not only feasible in my mind is
unquestionably achievable now over the
next five years I hope to be able to
write a paper that I think we're going
to be able to do it may take ten years
but hopefully in five years that we've
actually turned the tide on that if we
implement the things that we already
have and I've spoken to several of you
today about the issue of implementation
science but if you implement what we
already have with a little extra dose of
a vaccine and possibly some cure work
that the title of this is going to be
controlling and ultimately ending the
HIV
pandemic and achieved gold thank
it's not going to come from PEPFAR who's
going to do it here who's going to fund
implementation science and do all the
things you said that need to be done
with the tools we have today okay so I
do think that it is the role of the NIH
to be able to participate in funding
implementation research I really do
think that PEPFAR and the Global Fund
and the Gates Foundation and others
should be investing more in fact PEPFAR
in fairness to them has a program in
which they've divided several millions
of dollars 15 million in the first year
to us to me to CDC and to USAID to do
implementation research the difficulty
and in its as you know probably better
than anybody the idea of doing
implementation research from a
fundamental basic and clinical research
organization there's a lot of pushback
on that from the Congress and others who
fund that well somebody else should be
doing that and that's the reason why
when Eric Goosby was the was the
director of PEPFAR we came to an
agreement that he said I have some money
and implementation is important from the
success of the PEPFAR program with you
guys partner with us and that's how we
started it was me and Tom Frieden and
and Raja so you're absolutely right we
need to do it
there's got to be more questions in
there Jerry summarize 30 some-odd years
of HIV so brilliantly and succinctly so
and thank you so thinking forward and
and this is an implementation question
as well we probably have the resources
here to enable implementation but the
full force of the epidemic has passed
and with lots of residual here that we
have to deal with of course but in areas
like South Africa or work why work and
the rest of the world implementation
remains really so dependent upon the
strength of the health system and and
the will and the political will of
leadership so and that so this is and I
guess my custom abhi how you and others
leaders really see your role and have
not have and will continue to see a row
in terms of maintaining that the view
that this is a global epidemic and that
one that just affects the US and with
great concerns that we all have that
they'll be diminished in interest in the
global epidemic into the future as
things actually settled an increasingly
improve here yeah that was a clear
question it wasn't we're worried about
the rest of the world as we actually
probably can achieve the goal ear what's
going to happen where actually the
resources are not just the research and
the implementation resources but the
basic resources of the infrastructure in
the countries that we serve it's it's a
very relevant Jerry and and and but a
complicated question with the
complicated answer but let me try and be
as simple as I possibly can the
relationship between implementation and
a health care system is absolutely
essential and the better we get with the
full implementation of the Affordable
Care Act the full implementation of Ryan
why I think will be do much better in
this country to do that what I'm trying
to do and I am you know hopefully we'll
be able to do it in the next 15 months
of the administration and hopefully the
next administration would be interested
in it also is to show some
demonstrations in some particular cities
that if you actually apply in a very
intense way with HIV I mean you it
should apply to every disease that you
can actually bring the epidemic down to
essentially nothing San Francisco is
doing a fantastic job on that we started
in Washington DC and brought it from the
worst place in the country to now doing
very well I actually think if you're
looking at the political climate of what
makes people move and do things they
like to see results so if you could take
some representative cities like
Washington San Francisco Oakland Atlanta
and Baltimore which is the five that
we're concentrating not that the others
aren't equally is worthy but we've made
connections with that and prove that you
can do that I think that there will be
government resources to do just what you
saying people are forgetting about not
forgetting about but I'm not paying much
attention to globally is a different
story it's very interesting that we have
to continue to fight against that the
way things are right now with funding
things are so tight and there's so much
conflict between ideologies in
Washington that were held hostage to
that even though most people agree that
this is a good thing to do again Rwanda
is a great example of what can be done
and I think if we get Rwanda to really
go down the other countries might look
around and say hey maybe we should be
making more an investment in you know in
healthcare systems the idea of
investment in health care systems is
emerging now as the real global problem
I mean people are starting to get it
there would not have been an Ebola
catastrophe in West Africa if they had
even the slightest semblance of a
healthcare system it wouldn't have
happened
it just wouldn't have happened but it
exploded just because of that I think
people are starting to get that yeah
and increasingly we're recognizing that
chronic viral infections are driving a
number of chronic diseases what are your
thoughts about what we can learn about
the study of chronic viral infections
more generally in terms of controlling
chronic disease from our experience with
HIV good question there's a little bit
of a disconnect not in your question but
in in the concepts because what we are
trying to do struggling with is
identifying an unknown virus that might
be triggering a chronic what appears to
be non infectious disease all right no
no let me finish it there's two aspects
of it does that if you're saying that
this looks like it's some sort of an
immunological response to an infectious
disease chronic fatigue syndrome Oh what
what have you and then there's the
associations of you know HPV hepatitis C
hepatitis B you know sorrow megalo RCB
virus I think the more we study this the
more we're going to realize that there
are connections there and that's the
reason why we're working on trying to
develop an EBD vaccine of people so what
do you need any diva vaccine I think the
EBV vaccine is going to be a big
breakthrough if we have the EBV vaccine
the difficulty with with making it not
like i said the disconnect there's not
only a question with HIV is really a
different story HIV is a clear highly
replicative virus that takes a long time
on the most circumstances because it
acts indirectly in killing the host as
opposed to for the most part directly
that's what I meant by the disconnect
dr. Baccio a question over here oh it's
a real honor to have you here and I
actually had two questions one is
molecular and then one is more based in
public health but I was curious about
your comment about the tailored
immunogen approach to the development of
a vaccine and you had mentioned also
very briefly that certain broadly
neutralizing antibodies have unusual
traits such as auto reactivity and then
as you closed out that component of your
talk you said you were basically the
idea of iterative immunogen's was to try
to get the body to do something that
doesn't want to do so I was wondering if
you could comment whether there's a
connection there is there's some sort of
autoreactive component or something like
that please yeah okay so it's a very
good question not all of the antibodies
have autoreactive capabilities the
antibodies against the membrane proximal
external domain the Emperor are very
strongly weighted towards auto
reactivity board Haynes has done a bunch
of studies to show that to a greater or
lesser extent several of the antibodies
have Auto reactivity and the reason he
thinks is one of the reasons why we
don't make it is because of Tolerance
mechanisms and that if you actually it
isn't that you're going to induce an
autoimmune response if you induce a
vaccine responds with an antigen is that
if it's being controlled by tolerance
mechanism can you break tolerance to the
specific antigen without triggering
autoimmunity so you're absolutely right
that's one of the things that breaking
tolerance may be one of the things we
need to do in addition to finding the
right germline b-cell to engage with
okay thank you and then my other
question was somewhat to what's already
been addressed here but in terms of your
full-throated in very impressive
comments about the United States not
being wherever Wanda is in terms of
having viral suppression among only
thirty percent of people living with HIV
and AIDS and then you mentioned learning
from San Francisco and learning from
some of the urban areas I wondered if
you as a molecular scientist but also
someone with this public health
perspective could comment specifically
on some of the issues like for example
in the rural southern US where we have a
serious kind of stable problem and this
50,000 cases
year how can we bridge these issues with
all the molecular work and also this
very powerful need not only to deal with
urban areas but also nation national
nationwide can we learn from Rwanda
maybe you have some specific how do we
bridge these two fields and how do we
learn in the United States from other
countries that are doing better on this
so I'm not so sure that you need to
bridge the field of molecular
conformation of an imogen with which is
going on in Alabama I think you just
need to do both I I would reframe your
question if you'd allow me to do is that
should we be putting as much effort into
both in other words finding all the
molecular nuances of things if you don't
address the problem that we're having in
the southern part of the country where
we're having you know ongoing outbreaks
of HIV is is is not appropriate so
that's how I would answer it that we
absolutely need to do both the situation
in the southern part of the United
States is is a real big issue because
it's a combination of so many different
things of poor health care systems you
know minority stigma poverty all kinds
of sociological things that go into the
fact that where there wasn't an epidemic
like that years ago now that's if you
look at the map of the United States and
you do a heat map on it that part of the
country lights up as you well know from
your question I just think we need to do
both thank you yeah
thank you so much for your talk so
recently we've seen there's been quite
about a lot of publicity about the high
prices of drugs that have come to market
and I think it's wonderful that niaD is
investing so much in research for a
vaccine and I was wondering if there's a
plan to regulate the price of the
vaccine should have come to market to
ensure that access is not limited to
those who can afford it yeah it's going
to be very it's going to be very
different with the we go out to the
price in a vaccine in fact I don't want
to how do I say so I don't get quoted
badly I think with regard to a vaccine I
think it's going to be likely close to
free I mean I don't think there's going
to be a vaccine for HIV that's going to
be three hundred dollars of vaccine I
think that what's going to happen is
that because of the amount of money that
will be saved by preventing a single
infection that that that that's going to
get bought up by governments it's going
to get bored up by gavi it's going to
get bought up by a whole bunch of groups
that I don't I I worry so much less
about the price of a vaccine as to
whether we're going to get a vaccine
don't worry about that it's not it's
it's not going to happen first of all
the vaccines are being developed in
academia and when we license it out now
to these companies there's clearly going
to be with the provision that it's going
to be at a price that is miniscule when
I mean really miniscule
yeah but see what we love you indeed I
can give you a simple answer that's not
true but let me give you the curve the
right answer that's complicated years
ago we had something when we had the
bayh-dole act about the the Peter knows
this better than anybody god help us
Peter hut formally FDA my colleague for
many years ago we we had this thing
called the reasonable price clause that
if the you license out a product that
was made by government investment to a
company that they would have to charge a
reasonable price the only thing is 35
congressional hearings later we could
never figure out whether reasonable
price was to some people me a reasonable
price means something that a poor
country can afford a reasonable price to
some companies means after I pay for all
of the research that failed over the
last 30 years and that's how you get an
80 thousand dollar drug so you're asking
how we do it I don't even think it's
going to be a problem because the
vaccine is going to be made with a very
heavy input from the federal government
and companies that we contract with
under the agreement that you will never
test a vaccine in a country in which the
vaccine would not be readily available
to them at an affordable price that's a
business decision and it's an ethical
decision so there's no way that you're
going to do a trial like we're doing in
South Africa and then get a vaccine that
cost four hundred dollars a shot that's
it I mean that's a contract you can't do
that no no I mean I don't even need luck
it's going to happen trust me it's
different it's different than then drugs
drugs are a different story drugs of a
different story because there's no doubt
that the government's for example the
government of South Africa if the
companies that we're partnering with two
to manufacture a particular protein
decide they want to charge a lot we'll
just get the protein and make it
ourselves and break the patent in a
microsecond that would be it right
you started out your talk this afternoon
by talking a little bit about the change
in the demographics or population that's
infected in the United States can you
say a little bit more about that in
terms of whether that's on can you say a
little something more about that in
terms of the population that's infected
today is it purely have to do we've
talked a little bit about access to
healthcare and things like that or are
there other biological reasons reasons
why it might have shifted and then I
actually have a follow-on question okay
has nothing to do with a Python now let
me answer that first so if you look at
the demography of new infections it's
about sixty-five percent men who have
sex with men of that group among men if
you look at males fifty-five percent of
those are in african-americans so
african-americans are twelve to thirteen
percent of the population and they
comprise fifty-five percent of all new
infections and a higher percentage of
the men who have sex with men and that
has to do with a lot of things that has
to do with a combination of access to
care a much greater stigma among
african-american men who have sex with
men then white men who have sex with men
just in the community in the church in
everything it's it's it's a very
different situation I mean it's tough to
generalize but in general it's a very
different situation if you look at the
new infections among women in the United
States sixty-five percent of them are
among african-american women and it's an
interesting combination of sociology and
epidemiology because if you look at the
sexual habits of heterosexually infected
african-american women their sexual
activity and habits is no different than
the white population so there's this
misconception that they're having more
sex in most sexual pause they're not
it's a question of essentially being in
the wrong place at the wrong time take
Washington DC before we got involved in
putting a full-court press if you look
at it the
the prevalence of infection in the city
was like three point seven percent among
young african-american men the
prevalence was five point eight percent
in Washington DC which is worse than
about seventeen African countries so if
you happen to be a young
african-american woman who more likely
would be having sex with a young
african-american man the chances of your
coming into contact with an infected
person is infinitely greater than if
your cohort of sexual partners has a
prevalence of 0.1 and that's pure
numbers so it's the sociology is wrong
place at the wrong time lack of access
to healthcare and a variety of other
things that's what I meant by being
complicated
you know I don't have the correct number
for that but it's it's substantial in
people who are infected in prisons but
the issue what happens in prisons is
that in the most prison systems today if
you get infected you get treated what
happens is when they get out of prison
they go off medical care their viral
load goes up they infect people and then
they wind up getting sick but the exact
percentage of that I could find that Alf
way I don't have that there's one final
question some gentleman on the back
maybe
yeah time what pearls of wisdom do you
have for young people that seek to be
leaders in the next generation of health
care seek to be leaders okay well
leadership is a big category so with the
first thing that I tell people young
people who ask me about you know advice
about Korea leadership is in my mind
very heavily weighted towards leadership
by example as opposed to leadership by
position so my advice is if you really
feel that it's in you to be a leader
then you have to start doing things that
are leadership things in other words do
things that might not be the commonly
accepted thing to do you know sometimes
when you're doing things that ultimately
get you to be a leader you don't even
know that you're heading towards
leadership you might be heading towards
criticism you know seriously I mean I'm
looking at at at Greg in the front row
when I did something years and years ago
about feeling that it was very very
important to get the activist community
very much involved in the design the
implementation of clinical trials the
discussion of the regulatory process at
the time I was severely criticized by my
scientific colleagues they thought i was
nuts to doing that because the activist
was so provocative and and
confrontational but i still did that so
back in 1988 i was criticized by the
scientific community you told me that I
was not fit to be the leader of the
Institute because I was partnering with
the activist 25 years later i'm the
leader for having done that
so what you need to do is to just by
example but also don't be afraid to do
things that are not particularly popular
and do things that you feel are that you
feel passionately about I think the best
leaders of the people who are passionate
about what it is that they're doing
because people sense your passion and
then you all of a sudden become a leader
for them so when you feel passionate
about something go for it what a
fabulous way to end a charge
thank you for a tour de force as Jerry
said of 30 years of research and a
vision of the future and more
importantly for all you have done over
your career to improve the health of
populations domestically and abroad so
thank you so so much
and doctor
they'll be a reception on both levels of
Harkness and we're going to give dr.
foggia opportunity to drink some water
but he open to conversation so join us
in a reception outside
you